So this is, this is very interesting.
I want to take a little bit of a break from
serious politics for a second a and not that
the alleged rape by Donald Trump of a 13 year
old along with Jeffrey Epstein is not serious,
but I want to just take a step back and show
you just an example of Donald Trump being
the totally triggered snowflake that we know
him to be at one of his own rallies.
So as you know, just to very quickly sort
of reset, Jeffrey Epstein has now been arrested
on really serious child sex trafficking charges.
As you also may know, there are long standing
allegations against Donald Trump and Epstein
for raping the same 13 year old girl at Epstein's
Manhattan, New York City condo.
Years ago, Trump recently did one of his Mageau
rallies in Duluth, Minnesota.
There was a protester in the crowd holding
up a picture of Donald Trump with Jeffrey
Epstein because again, they used to be friends.
They used to hang out.
Now I would put the picture on the screen
for you.
It's a very well known picture, but the pictures,
copyright is held by Getty images, which is
one of the most aggressive bogus copyright
claimants around.
So I'm not going to do that.
But you can easily find the picture online.
If you do a Google image search for Donald
Trump.
Jeffrey Epstein, Trump is on the right in
the picture, a Epstein to Epstein's left that
would be with his arm around Jeffrey Epstein's.
So at Trump's Duluth, Minnesota rally, this
is just great.
A protestor or an audience member, I guess
you could call them.
How, how to blown up version of this picture.
And you can see as Donald Trump is talking,
he notices it and he does kind of a double
take.
And then he clearly recognizes it.
And that's already kind of interesting because
it means very clearly the Epstein stuff is
on Trump's mind that Trump from this far away
would instantly recognize what the picture
is of.
And Trump immediately starts calling for the
guy holding the picture to be removed.
He interrupts his own speech.
And brilliantly the Fox News feed actually
showed the guy holding the blown up picture
and the content of the picture itself.
I was actually thinking maybe this is what
Trump saw over the weekend on Fox that angered
him so much that he went on that crazy anti
Fox News Twitter storm over the weekend.
In any case, checkout our president more than
70 years old, triggered so strongly by a picture
of him with one of his friends that he interrupts
his own speech and calls even more attention
to the guy and then obviously the 70 plus
year old billionaire president starts insulting
the guy holding the picture with red meat
for the Trump istock audience.
Joking about the gender identity of the guy
because oh my goodness, it's a guy with long
hair, which obviously is what we would make
fun of.
Let's take a look at the video.
You have to mark up thousands of miles coming
through Mexico.
You come up thousands of miles coming through
Mexico and we're it to stop it.
Get them out of here.
Get Him Outta here.
Go home to your mob darling.
Go home to get them out of here out [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
was that a man or a woman?
Because he needs a haircut more than I do.
[inaudible]
the chance of USA USA are almost fitting in
a sense USA, USA, where our president is accused
of rape and sexual assault 15 times still
becomes president and then kicks out of his
speeches.
Anybody who calls attention to his friendly,
uh, relationships with his co a co, a co alleged
perpetrator, I guess we would call them the
crowd chance USA as a protestor is ejected
for holding up a picture of Trump with a man
he allegedly conspired with to rape a 13 year
old.
We don't have to read dystopian science fiction
of hundreds of years from now or 50 years
from now.
I mean, this is the dystopia.
Understand this is how Trump takes back control
with gender identity jokes.
Trump is accused of raping a 13 year old with
his friend Jeffrey Epstein.
Epstein gets arrested, the allegations are
horrible.
Someone in the audience has a picture of Trump
with Epstein and Trump gets the crowd back
on his side.
Instead of being concerned about the allegations,
the crowd is riotous over Trump making fun
of whether it's a boy or a girl because hey,
they have long hair and long hair is for girls
and the crowd goes absolutely bonkers.
How funny, right?
A boy with long hair, it's like he's a girl
in some way.
The president of the United States making
fun of men for having long hair, which is
extra strange by the way, considering Donald
Trump looks just like his own mother and that's
not, I mean it's not a joke.
Trump looks just like his own mother.
I'm not sure if you've seen pictures, but
who cares?
This is what the guy in the glass house is
choosing to throw stones about.
He's accused of raping a child and someone
holds up a picture and this is how the president
behaves.
The world is laughing, the world is laughing
and it is going to take years, if not a decade.
Once Trump finally is gone to rebuild the
relationships that he has embarrassingly destroyed.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at David Dot.
Pacman where you can ask me questions about
this.
Are any other stories from today's show?
Follow the show on Instagram as well at David
[inaudible], the David Pakman show@davidpacman.com